there's only one week left to have your
say on our draft annual plan and if the
sunday trading we're here at the Oxford
a MP show is to find out what the locals
have to say
[Music]
do you think that shot should be given
the option to open for trading on Easter
Sunday yeah I think much w option I
think it's nice to have a few days of
the shops closed will be quite honest
with you Christmas Day and Easter I
think they should stay shut if they
choose to i think must give the option
it doesn't really hurt have a day where
you don't need to go to the summon shop
most shops are shut on them and the
weekends and the hell of people get it
is a good stuff yo yeah most of the open
no one else is open to go for it but
that one I believe it will shut simple
is that enough I would prefer they
weren't yeah yeah i definitely don't
mind yeah i'm not bothered whether they
open on a sunday or not i think they
were really very times yeah i think so
yeah yeah okay and then people choose if
they want to shuffle they don't like
[ __ ]
[Music]
after staff on a week that's long enough
staff need the time off but stuff
another day the year to me so I've got
shopping for sure if they want to pay
the extra and people want to shop why
not let's be a choice we can all do the
day off right sure we can supply one day
you've heard what they have to say what
do you think let's talk Easter trading
is just one topic covered in our draft
and your friends visit Waimakariri govt
seems you're in said to find out more
and have your say
you
[Music]